buon pomeriggio io sono una specie di
farlo d'arte parlo d'altro rispetto a
quello che si è detto oggi si è parlato
di start up di volani invenzioni che
possono farci vedere il domani già un po
oggi quello di cui parlo io è
effettivamente sta dentro questo
contenitore anche se su un piano
lievemente diverso meno pragmatico io
non sono un imprenditore io insegno
prima all'accademia di belle arti poi
all'università di bologna arte
contemporanea e sono stata per dieci
anni il direttore di una fiera d'arte
d'arte moderna e contemporanea fiera
internazionale che è stata la più
importante è la più importante d'italia
ed è stata anche una delle a detta di un
sito importante americano una delle
prime sei del mondo si chiama arte fiera
la mia prima immagine si chiama così
potevo farlo anch'io ho rubato questo
titolo da prima un libro e poi una
trasmissione su sky come vedete di un
critico e curatore italiano molto
conosciuto anche all'estero che si
chiama francesco bonami che ha
intitolato una trasmissione è appunto un
saggio su questo tema lo potevo fare
anch'io che è una frase che chi si
occupa d'arte contemporanea sia da
fruitore che da presentatore si è
sentito dire
diecimila volte lo potevo fare questo lo
potevo fare anch'io
ed è una frase che al di là del
così nel senso anche magari un po
corrente un po banale nasconde però una
concezione un pregiudizio molto forte
nei confronti dell'arte contemporanea
che che è questo rispetto all'arte
antica per l'arte contemporanea non è
necessario avere delle competenze
tecniche delle abilità tecniche chiunque
può fare qualsiasi cosa
tanto che lo potevo fare anch'io che non
sono artista parentesi li poteva esserci
che non sono un artista e quindi che
l'arte contemporanea sia così un po una
specie di campo rinchiuso una riserva
indiana per un élite che gli
intellettuali che un po se la racconta
che dice di capire cose dove non c'è
niente da capire che dice di apprezzare
un vasetto di fiori che riconosce come
altro da un vasetto di fiori è un ambito
considerato per un elite
io come come mia esperienza personale
avevo studiato e dello studioso e
insegnavo l'arte fino alla prima metà
del novecento come mia esperienza poi mi
è capitato questa curiosa così avventura
nella vita capitano quasi sempre per
caso di
essere richiamata dal io collaboravo con
arte fiera face scrivevo comunicati
stampa portavo in giro quelli che
vengono chiamati vips illustravo le
opere che c'erano così ma venne chiamata
dal presidente di allora di bologna
fiere che era luca cordero di
montezemolo il quale mi disse a me
questa fiera piace molto di fiere
importanti in fondo in italia c'è solo
questa
te la senti di farne una fiera
importante internazionale io non ho
dormito tre notti perché io non avevo
mai avuto a che fare col mercato con le
gallerie con la fiera scrivevo
comunicati ma se me lo faceva sempre
dall'esterno non conoscevo il mercato
dell'arte sistema dell'arte
contemporanea
dopo tre notti ho accettato la scommessa
era una sfida lontana dalle dalle mie
abitudini di studio ho cominciato a
viaggiare il mondo per vedere come erano
le fiere come erano le altre fiere
poi ho capito poi ci ho pensato e ho
capito una cosa che le altre fiere si
tenevano in luoghi come madrid berlino
parigi londra new york miami ora bologna
era un po più complicato se è più facile
convincere la gente andare a fare un
weekend in ottobre a parigi piuttosto
che venire nei giorni della candelora
cioè l'ultimo week end di gennaio a
bologna e questo è stato un problema che
mi sono posta pragmaticamente forse un
uomo non l'avrebbe fatto una donna lo fa
dice magari chi è che di io devo dire
degli americani che il momento giusto
per venire in italia e gennaio a bologna
con la neve dove l'aereo porta quasi
sempre chiuso vabbè allora ho pensato
bisogno che io gli attiri c'è bisogno
perché una fiera ce n'è tanta e di fiere
quelli sì vabbè quella lì non ci vado
perché scomoda perché in una stagione
sfigata non buona e allora
ho pensato come attirarli io ero avevo
competenze solo di storia dell'arte
allora pensato sai come vendiamo questa
città che nessuno vende mai allora sto
parlando io ho cominciato nel 2003
adesso con grandissimo piacere vedo che
invece ci sono tanti turisti sono è
molto più frequentata bologna allora
meno ho detto vendiamo la città allora
sono andata in giro
facevo delle presentazioni gli
raccontavo delle cose che neanche i
bolognesi sanno solitamente e poi gli
dicevo la più antica università del
mondo
e poi c'è la ferrari e poi c'è la ducato
che c'era lamborghini gliela vende va in
mille modi gli americani erano molto
sensibile a questa cosa e e poi gli ho
detto poi a bologna succede una cosa che
nessun altra fiera succede cioè l'arte
non è solo dentro i padiglioni della
fiera non è come sempre in questo luogo
dedicato agli addetti ai lavori doveva
solo chi è interessato che ha curioso ma
noi organizzeremo una grande mostra a
cielo aperto nel centro storico di
bologna nei luoghi più belli di bologna
centro storico il bologna è uno dei più
vasti del mondo con monaco a venezia
sono pochi comunque si contano sulle
punta delle dita è un centro storico
bellissimo e nei luoghi più affascinanti
ci saranno installazioni d'arte
contemporanea e questa è stata la come
dire una sorta di piccola invenzione
sull'altra basata proprio sulla
tradizione perché il richiamo io capivo
non essere tanto per un pubblico vasto
quello delle opere d'arte contemporanea
ma il richiamo vero era appunto quello
di mettere quello che io dicevo prima lo
so fare anch'io perché chiunque ha visto
un quadro di lucio fontana
se lo dice magari tra sé e sé in grande
segreto e silenzio ha pensato beh ho
capito quello lì lo potevo fare anch'io
questa è una cosa che abbiamo pensato
tutti
non mi sogno adesso di raccontarvi
perché fontana cosa voleva fare perché
se lo facciamo noi non viene mai così
provate per credere prendete una boiata
da un supermercato una tele e provata e
vedrete che il taglio vi viene sempre
peggio non vi viene mai così non è vero
che è lo potevo fare anch'io ma non è
questo il tema il tema è quello di
portare questa arte questo linguaggio
che è la nostra contemporaneità cioè che
è quello che noi oggi siamo dentro a un
contenitore tale per cui le persone le
persone normali noi le persone non io
che su studio quelle cose ma tanti di
voi e tanti amici miei che vanno il
sabato pomeriggio in centro a fare due
passi che vanno che entrano volentieri a
vedere una mostra marcia che non sono
gli appelli si imbattessero in quella
che solitamente viene considerata
qualcosa di complicato
e allora è partita questa esperienza di
queste installazioni di arte
contemporanea appunto ho preso l'esempio
di fontana che è il più banale che
potevo prendere queste questi opere
d'arte contemporanea collocate nei
luoghi più prestigiosi più belli della
città nel cortile dell'archiginnasio nel
cortile di palazzo d'accursio dentro ai
musei e ai musei universitari dentro ad
esempio alla sala delle delle cere
anatomiche che è una cosa meravigliosa
sembra di essere in un posto magico
dentro al museo archeologico nel in
piazza maggiore nella chiesetta che
quasi nessuno vedeva e che in qualche
modo è diventata invece protagonista che
c'è la chiesetta dei carcerati quella
che c'è a palazzo re enzo con dentro
dell'installazione ha cominciato e spera
era una scommessa
speriamo che questa cosa funzioni che le
persone apprezzino che vadano a vedere
queste cose magari una scusa per andare
all'archiginnasio passi di lievi di
quello là
organizzammo un nome era art white night
perché si dà il nome inglese fa sempre
più effetto e allora perché era una
notte bianca guardate che adesso ci sono
note di tutti i colori da quella lì però
è stata la notte bianca dell'arte la
prima nel 2005 è stata la prima che è
stata fatta e ed è stata veramente una
scommessa perché il tempo è
fortunatamente non pioveva quel sabato
sera erano tutti i musei aperti era
un'offerta per tutti i cittadini per
tutti gli ospiti che venivano da fuori
per vedere centro storico di bologna a
girare
certo in gennaio quindi con la pelliccia
però insomma comunque per girare fuori
casualmente che quella notte fu una
notte tiepida e meravigliosa e io mi
sono commossa perché per le strade di
bologna quella notte del 27 enti 6 27
gennaio nel 2005 poi del 2006 e quelle
2007 c'erano più di 100.000 persone che
camminavano per le strade entravano nei
musei entravano guardavano le opere
questo era un installazione
archiginnasio di un artista che si
chiama ama con artista tedesco vedete
tutta la gente moltissimi ragazzi questa
installazione è stata acquistata dalla
università bocconi e chi va alla bocconi
la vede emessa parete non per terra
la vede alla parete della bocconi tanta
gente tantissima gente questa è una
scultura di arnaldo pomodoro nel cortile
dell'archiginnasio e poi alla fine della
notte bianca ci furono i fuochi
d'artificio e bologna sembrava veramente
in festa ed era veramente una festa
dell'arte
io sono rimasta commossa dicevo perché
in realtà si è creato un abitudine per
cui i bolognesi e anche tanti ospiti da
fuori bologna hanno cominciato
se si aspettavano un la notte bianca si
aspettavano i luoghi storici abitati da
opere d'arte contemporanea che non erano
estranee corpi estranei che non
erano difficili da capire ma che erano
arte quella di oggi che parlava e viveva
insieme a quella di ieri che è stata
contemporanea ieri che forse è stata
difficile ieri da capire per chi viveva
in quel periodo
charles baudelaire il grande poeta
francese che amava della croix non
poteva vedere gli impressionisti ma vi
se questa famosa frase ogni epoca una
sua bellezza e noi abbiamo il dovere di
comprenderla e quindi guardava gli
impressionisti guardava maneri cerati
rom e che pena però zitto perché quella
era l'arte deglu capiva che quello era
il linguaggio del suo tempo
questa è una delle cose che tengono il
mio cuore più in modo più caro nella
storia della mia vita questi due
personaggi che vedete che si applaudono
sono quella destra si chiama bill viola
è il più grande e video artista che ci
sia vivente oggi quella sinistra si
chiama arvo part è il più grande campo
uno dei più grandi compositori di musica
contemporanea vivente sono riuscita a
farli venire tutti e due a bologna a
fare una serata unico nella loro storia
una serata insieme a nella chiesa
sconsacrata di santa cristina
una serata che è stata il cui video è
stato ricomprato comprato da 40
televisioni nel mondo e la gente veniva
venivano di notte da torino per essere
lì e poter partecipare a questa a questa
serata
l'arte contemporanea quindi parla a
tutti e io li ho capito che bisognava
semplicemente buttare giù le barriere
abbattere le barriere perché il contempo
l'arte contemporanea è quella che noi
vediamo un bambino concludo con due
parole
mio nipote lo portavo in giro con
patatine
pop corn e coca cola e un pezzettino di
museo e lui veniva con molto piacere
alla quarta volta che lo portava in giro
gli ho detto andiamo in un museo lui mi
ha detto sì ma andiamo a vedere delle
cose nuove
mica quelli che guardano tutti con gli
occhi in su che erano i quadri di guido
reni perché un bambino di sei anni
quello lì non gli assomiglia non ha
nulla a che vedere con la sua vita con
la sua realtà con la sua quotidianità
mentre si divertiva in quelli d'arte
contemporanea perché vedi con vedeva
cose che conosceva ecco quindi l'arte
contemporanea è la nostra
contemporaneità che ha le radici senza
l'innovazione non potremo mai conservare
questo straordinario patrimonio che
abbiamo di tradizione artistica se noi
non guardassimo cosa si fa oggi allora
con la stesso spirito così tanto sempre
sveglia 3 notti con la stessa scommessa
che avevo fatto con arte fiera la mia
collaborazione con arte fiera si è
conclusa nel 2012 e sto collaborando a
un progetto di giovani giovane critiche
di giovani artisti e giovani critiche si
chiama laura petrillo sta tra bologna e
sasso marconi e londra che trovo
bellissimo questa possibilità di stare
tra sasso marconi e londra e ed ha
creato un progetto cui appunto io
partecipo per cui si va ogni anno alle
mostre finali delle delle accademie
dell'università d'arte europee a londra
a vienna in italia e si scelgono una
commissione in cui l'unica italiana
peraltro sono io
oltre appunto laura che è
l'organizzatrice si scelgono i giovani
che talenti più interessanti che a noi
sembrano parlare un linguaggio nuovo che
sembrano dire qualcosa di nuovo e questi
noi li andiamo a proporre attraverso
delle mostre attraverso dei video a
collezionisti e galleristi a musei alle
persone che amano e che si interessano
di arte contemporanea
questo questa nuova scommessa io sono
anziane con dei giovani artisti mi ha
dato veramente una nuova carica e vi
vorrei dire che l'arte qualsiasi arte ma
anche quella contemporanea vi migliora
la qualità della vita credetemi
grazie